c'est vrai qu'en France toujours des
rôles de beurette des cités qui galèrent
alors que vous avez jamais vécu dans une
cité vous avez pas beaucoup galéré quoi
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir sofia Boutella
bonsoir
alors Sofia dans les années 80 vous êtes
à Alger vous êtes dans un magasin de
musique avec votre père qui lui-même
musicien il vous propose d'acheter des
cassettes ils ont choisi ces trois
Madonna Michael Jackson et Tina Turner
et 15 ans plus tard en février dernier
avec Madonna au Super Bowl vous dansez
devant 100 millions de téléspectateurs
waouh
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h
[Musique]
Sofia rebonsoir vous êtes né le 3 avril
1982 à Bab El Oued un quartier populaire
d'Alger votre père et sa fille Boutella
compositeur diplômé de la berkli College
of Music de Boston qui connaîtra la
consécration 5 ans plus tard avec Coutu
le premier album de Khaled voilà votre
main interchitecte
alors tous les jours votre père prend le
temps de vous initier à la musique qui
dit viens je vais te laver les oreilles
il me faisait écouter de tout vraiment
et même des choses que je ne comprenais
pas et mais ça m'a vraiment ouvert les
yeux c'est une chance bien sûr alors
c'est comme ça qu'un jour dans un
magasin de musique il vous propose
d'acheter vos premières cassettes et
vous choisissez Madonna Michael Jackson
et Tina Turner
alors enfant vous ne rêvez pas de
devenir danseuse mais astronaute
éleveur de dauphins et Médecins sans
frontières en fait la danse c'est une
activité assez naturelle que vous
pratiquez dès l'âge de 5 ans en tutu
dans des cours de danse classique à
Alger
j'avais un tutu des collants roses
j'avais tout l'attirail et c'était ce
qui au départ m'excité alors en 1992
votre famille s'installe en France et un
jour vous dites alors que je revenais de
l'école on est allé directement à
l'aéroport on a quitté le pays je me
rendais pas compte moi à l'époque de ce
que ça représentait de partir de son
pays mais je sais que j'allais vers
quelque chose où les opportunités
étaient plus ouvertes en fait à 10 ans
vous découvrez Paris mais sans galère en
fait moi je m'en rendais pas compte
c'est peut-être ensuite par la suite je
me suis rendu compte que j'étais pas
comme les autres enfants de de l'école
moi j'ai grandi à l'école en Algérie on
partait tous un tablier on était tous
les mêmes et je sais qu'on faisait
vachement attention à ce que je portais
à ce que je m'étais comment je
m'exprimais comment je parlais je suis
arrivée je suis rentrée en CM1 il me
semble et je savais pas très bien lire
et écrire le français et c'était
difficile de s'intégrer moi je le voyais
plus comme bon je vais arriver en France
il va avoir du Coca-Cola des bonbons des
magazines je vais pouvoir avoir accès à
certaines choses dont on n'avait pas
accès en tout cas à l'époque en Algérie
alors en 1992 année olympique vous
découvrez la gymnastique rythmique et
sportive grs et là vous prenez de
passion pour ça vous irez jusqu'au
championnat de France vous serez même
sélectionné en équipe nationale mais en
fait vous voyez pas aller aux Jeux
Olympiques quoi non non et là vous
découvrez le hip-hop c'est pas rien
alors quelques années plus tard vous
intégrez une troupe qui s'appelle
vagabonde crew champion du monde de
Battle en 2006
et vous dites pour moi ce qu'il faisait
était irréel c'était comme défier les
lois de la gravité
et c'était aller loin des des règles et
des formalités et de la tenue droite et
correcte et c'était défié aussi tout ça
alors à l'époque tous les jours après
les cours vous dansez au centre
commercial des Halles au Châtelet alors
en fait vous dansez au départ un peu
planqué quoi devant une animalerie c'est
un peu le spot des débutants là quoi je
sais pas aller au milieu là où là où les
bons sont et un jour un danseur confirmé
vous invite à danser au milieu de la
galerie marchande en public et là vous
découvrez le plaisir des
applaudissements le public oui oui très
nerveuse aussi et c'était un gros défi
pour moi l'apprentissage est difficile
vous avez le corps couvert de bleu
vous êtes courageuse et en plus surtout
j'étais très très souple hyperlax et
difficile pour moi de contenir mon
énergie et d'être plus dur alors à 19
ans vous songez à faire de la danse un
métier avec les vagabonde clou vous
découvrez la fièvre des battles vous
voyagez de ville en ville et vous
commencez à vous faire un petit nom dans
les festivals hip-hop avec un show qui
s'appelle chienne de vie c'est
l'histoire de plusieurs personnes qui
qui ont vécu une belle vie à un moment
donné et
c'est l'histoire de comment leur vie est
descendue est devenu est devenu pauvre
et c'est l'histoire de beaucoup de
de beaucoup de personnes qui sont dans
la rue qui viennent de l'armée ou
l'histoire de coeur ou les gens qui
jouent mais c'était c'était un beau
choix à faire quelques mois plus tard
blanc Cali vous repère pour son nouveau
film qui s'appelle le défi alors là
votre avenir commence à se dessiner vous
dites c'est ce film qui m'a donné envie
de devenir actrice j'ai adoré la caméra
j'ai adoré ça j'ai adoré raconter des
histoires j'ai aussi grandi en regardant
beaucoup de films et je sais l'impact
que ça a eu sur moi et j'ai eu envie de
persévérer et d'apprendre plus et puis
un jour vous entendez parler d'un
casting pour Nike la marque recherche
une égérie féminine pour sa nouvelle
ligne il y a 260 participants et c'est
Jimmy King le chorégraphe de Madonna qui
choisit et alors il passe une journée
avoir des filles des filles il est pas
content ça va pas et quand il vous voit
il dit c'est elle c'est elle qui me faut
beaucoup d'auditions je sais que je
rentrais pas forcément dans la case qui
que les genres recherchés j'avais
toujours un quelque chose d'un peu
bizarre dans mon style où j'ai j'étais
pas à formelle et ça a marché bien pour
Jimmy King en tout cas pour ce projet là
donc il vous choisit évidemment vous
faites le clip et votre image va faire
le tour de la planète et quand vous
retournez aux Halles l'animalerie a été
transformé en magasin de sport et sur la
vitrine en fait il y a votre photo
ça représentait beaucoup pour moi
énormément et c'était c'était assez
étrange comme sentiment c'est vrai alors
voilà c'est grâce à Jamie King donc
chorégraphe de Madonna vous allez la
rencontrer et alors quand vous la voyez
pour la première fois en fait elle
s'approche de vous elle vous tend la
main vous dit enchanté j'aime beaucoup
ce que tu fais on a commencé avec des
rapports très très professionnels et et
en fait elle est très douce et elle nous
a beaucoup apporté mais en tout cas elle
vous engage pour sa tournée
et puis rapidement vous faites partie
des VIP c'est à dire les importants
dancers vous faites deux clips avec elle
un gap et sorry et là vous découvrez une
Madonna un peu différente de l'image
qu'on peut en avoir c'est à dire à la
fois prof et à la fois maman elle est
très maternelle et
elle fait toujours en sorte que ses
danseurs soient bien traités elle nous
donne vraiment l'envie elle aime
tellement ce qu'elle fait et ça l'a
toujours ce but d'élever les gens oui
qu'elle nous aime elle fête nos
anniversaires elle surveille notre
morale elle surveille notre alimentation
donc c'est quelqu'un effectivement de
très présent en fait énormément elle
fait toujours en sorte que son médecin
Jean-Michel qui est français qui est
extraordinaire elle fait toujours en
sorte qu'ils nous qui nous regarde qui
nous check pour pour notre énergie pour
tout quoi elle vous dit un jour je te
guiderai sur ton chemin quand même c'est
vraiment fort ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
appris alors votre consécration de Very
Important dancer VIP ce sera le Super
Bowl en février dernier donc c'est la
mi-temps du Super Bowl qui est vu par
100 millions de téléspectateurs dans le
monde avec elle on a quand même fait
beaucoup de dates où on a dansé devant
80 000 personnes ce qui est ce qui est
énorme mais mais oui c'était c'est ce
qui est excitant c'est que c'est là et
qu'on a le droit qu'à une seule chance
et puis c'est surtout
et c'était quand même et c'est énorme et
puis la scène elle était extraordinaire
et puis c'est aussi de voir le tout
comment il monte la scène en 6 minutes
et la re-démonter juste après et
performer c'était très excitant on est
loin de la belle ou de
alors voilà vous étiez aussi fan de
Michael Jackson et en 2009 vous passez
un casting pour la tournée de Michael
Jackson This Is It
Michael Jackson comme Jamie King comme
Madonna tombe sous votre chat vous êtes
déjà pris sur la tournée de Madonna donc
vous êtes dans une situation extrêmement
compliquée il insiste il vous appelle
personnellement
j'ai eu la chance de lui parler au
téléphone il était question par la suite
que je les rejoigne à la fin de la
tournée avec Madonna et malheureusement
il est décédé quand vous avez appris la
mort de Michael Jackson je vais appeler
votre père en lui disant mais ça peut
pas se terminer comme ça enfin c'est pas
possible vous étiez vraiment
effondré et finalement vous serez
l'héroïne du clip posthume donc de
Michael Jackson qui s'appelle Hollywood
Tonight c'était un miracle c'est un
miracle et c'était un honneur pour deux
raisons pour parce que c'était pour lui
et aussi pour incarner la vie d'une
danseuse à Los Angeles c'est beaucoup la
vie des danseurs c'est bien de le voir
dans un clip comme ça ouais alors
aujourd'hui vous vivez à Los Angeles
vous dites en France j'ai un côté
ethnique qui ne passe pas partout aux
USA les gens avancent avec moins de hier
c'est vrai qu'en France toujours des
rôles de beurette des cités qui galèrent
alors que vous avez jamais vécu dans une
cité vous avez pas beaucoup galéré quoi
oui quand on est comédien on doit pas
être axé que sur une chose et c'est la
même façon que j'ai voulu découvrir
plusieurs styles de danse moi je n'ai
pas envie artistiquement de rester
enfermé dans un seul style pour conclure
je vais dire la liste des stars pour
lesquelles vous avez dansé et c'est
assez ahurissant donc il y a Madonna
évidemment Michael Jackson sur un plan
posthume Jamiroquai Rihanna Black Eyed
Peas Gwen Stefani Mariah Carey et Usher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu